you've probably heard of Donald Trump he
wants to work in the White House
the presumptive Republican nominee for
president is rich and he says his skills
as a deal maker and business operator
will accompany him to the Oval Office
should he win the election in November
I'm a businessman did really well I will
be the greatest jobs president that God
ever created I tell you that there's a
little problem here though big big
problem
Donald Trump has never actually been
quite the businessman or the deal maker
he says he is a disclosure Trump sued me
a decade ago for a biography I wrote
Trump nation the art of being the Donald
seeing it unfairly described his
business history and his wealth the case
was dismissed in 2011 well no one ever
really wants to go to court I did learn
a lot about how Donald thinks of himself
so let's take a look at Trump on Trump
first there's Trump the real estate
mogul my name is Donald Trump and I'm
the largest real estate developer in New
York but Trump has never been the
largest New York real estate developer
by any measure he might have become a
significant force in Manhattan real
estate after building Trump Tower over
30 years ago but a series of failed
deals in a long debt binge left him on
the verge of personal bankruptcy in the
early 1990s
then there's Trump the business Titan I
want to make America great again we are
going to make America great again
we are going to make our country great
again but the only public company Trump
ever managed was his casino business
which he bankrupted four times and which
was never profitable in the wake of his
problems in his real estate and casino
businesses Trump essentially became a
human shingle licensing his name and
everything from other people's buildings
to vodka
mattresses steaks and even a board game
my new game is Trump the game there's
also Trump University from Bruce his
years of experience to the world of
business education with a launch of
Trump Universe while state law
enforcement officials say that Trump
University was a fraud Trump has said
that the courts are treating him
unfairly and that he'll reopen the
operation and it will be richer than
ever after he becomes president in
recent years Trump is a knack for
developing top-flight golf courses and
of course he's retained his talents as
an untiring self promoter and
entertainer in addition to his
successful reality TV shows he's also
tried his hand at professional wrestling
but being a promoter marketer and
entertainer isn't the same as being a
major businessman or entrepreneur lastly
there's Trump the mega bazillionaire he
likes to toss around huge numbers about
his wealth but those numbers change a
lot I'm really rich the total is eighty
seven hundred thirty seven million five
hundred and forty thousand dollars much
more than that but that's okay I want to
be conservative he could help clear up
confusion about how successful he
actually is by releasing his tax returns
but so far he's declined to do that I
really couldn't tell you what I'm worth
but it's it's not bad who knows maybe
it's all just a game